accueillons notre terrienne du samedi 20
heures morgan freeman bons soins
chaque année en france
plus de 200 mille femmes sont victimes
de violences physiques ou sexuelles de
la part de leur conjoint en 2013
129 sont mortes morgan avait failli être
l'une d'entre elles vous racontez votre
enfer dans un livre intitulé il m'a volé
ma vie publié chez xo éditions et dans
salut les terriens
[Musique]
morgan freeman rabon soir vous est tenue
le 21 juillet 1983 à villecresnes dans
le val de marne votre mère est française
elle travaille dans une agence de pub
votre père et égyptiens musiciens ils se
sont rencontrés au caire votre mère a
travaillé
à l'adolescence un choc terrible vous
apprenez que papa n'est pas votre père
biologique en 5e ont travaillé sur la
généalogie donc forcément j'étais amené
à poser des questions à mes parents puis
un jour ils se sont dit qu'il était
temps de me dire de me faire la chose et
donc un samedi matin ils m'ont appelé
m'ont annoncé que mon père n'était pas
mon père alors là vous commencez à vous
rebellez vous sécher les cours ou les
vivre une vie d'adulte
donc vous n'irez pas au bout de votre
bep de compta à 14 ans vous tomber
amoureuse de samuel oui le problème
c'est que vous êtes musulmane les juifs
cet amour impossible vous rend plus fort
l'impression de défier la société et
puis subitement samuel quitte la france
pour les états unis vous ne le verrez
que bien plus tard peu après le départ
de samuel vous retrouver du travail
comme serveuse dans un restaurant à la
défense vous mettez en ménage avec un
garçon qui s'appelle franck l'afsset
contente parce que c'est la vie dont
vous rêviez c'est la vie d'adulte vous
êtes tous les deux dans un appartement a
priori ça devrait bien se passer le
problème c'est que franck bull toute la
journée pendant que vous trimer comme
une malade car évidemment le couple
finit pas par s'effriter
et un jour de vous assister à un match
de foot où il ya un dénommé yacine qui
est plus connu sous le nom de yacine le
terrible ce yacine vient vers franck et
lui dit un jour morgan sera ma femme et
on aura plein d'enfants j'étais
estomaqué vous êtes aussi flatté oui
bien sûr flatter parce que on se dit
quel culot aussi même temps voir d'un
côté
et puis les franco égyptien aussi ça
crée des liens forcément c'est normal
vous quittez franck mais avec des
raisons quand même parce qu'à la fin
franck quand même faut dire la vérité il
prenait l'échec de loyer et il est
j'encaissais pour acheter des jeux vidéo
c'est vrai qu'à un moment vous avez
marre ça se comprend et puis assis nous
fait la cour une cour vraiment assidus
ou succomber oui vous installer avec
yacine dans le petit village où il vit
dans la grande banlieue ouest
tout va bien au début mais un soir
d'août 2007 vous dîner chez des amis
yacine devient hystérique ils essaient
de vous étranglez en fait il a entendu
dire que vous couchez toujours avec
franck parce que des rumeurs oui voilà
c'est dit rumeurs déjà avec francky se
passera rien c'est pas pour qu'il se
passe quelque chose après quoi la
cedh jalousie vous la trouvez la voix
effrayante et attirante oui voilà sans
le savoir ils suivent déjà sous son
emprise
dès lors dans le couple les disputes
explosent régulièrement pour en rien et
ensuite les coups pleuvent mais pour
vous en faites vous dit bah oui on se
bat on se dispute m'enfin à ce qu'est un
couple passionné vous défendez voilà
c'est l'amour vache
là vous retrouver enceinte
oui c'est trop tôt voulait avorter mais
quand vous allez faire l'échographie ou
laisse écouter son coeur à cet enfant et
une fois que j'ai entendu son coeur
battre ben j'ai pu le courage d'avoir tu
es malade vous garder l'enfant
c'est pendant la grossesse que la
violence s'installe
parce que vous ne vous défendez plus en
fait vous comptez sur la naissance de
cet enfant pour ouvrir les yeux de
yacine
j'ai beaucoup d'espoir
mais après l'accouchement la violence
redouble d'intensité
c'est là où c'est tragique c'est à dire
que pour pas vous frapper devant le
gosse il met en place le rituel du
compte à rebours
10 heures du matin
on sait qu'on couche le petit à 14
heures il va me dire dans quatre heures
je te défonce et de live il va vers son
compte à rebours alors à l'heure dite il
vous fait mettre debout les bras le long
du corps sans bouger il commence au
début par des coûts non porter ce qu'il
appelle des fans et puis si le passage à
tabac et là vous devenez son putching
ball quoi ça va commencer des claques
des coups de poing des coups de pied
partout enfin voilà ça va durer trois
ans vous devenez experte en maquillage
mais vous ne partez pas en fait il vous
fait peur il fait trop peur toujours
l'espoir qui à l'époque qui change aussi
ouais de l'udc et rire en octobre 2011
vous décidé de reprendre contact par
internet avec samuel votre premier amour
et au premier regard malgré le
maquillage c'est incroyable vous dit
mais mes tournées qui te fera pourquoi
l'a senti tout de suite là sentiez
vous allez voir les gendarmes du village
mais son résultat oui à plus nous quand
vous aurez des preuves mais en fait non
ils m'ont demandé de changer les
serrures comme si lui il allait rentrer
il a laissé dire à bâle a changé les
serrures c'est fini je m'en vais et un
dimanche matin
en allant faire des courses au
supermarché il voue pas dans la voiture
devant le gosse cette fois vous appeler
les gendarmes je leur précise que je
porte plainte et je suis prête à aller
jusqu'au bout de là ils me disent ok
porter plainte comparution immédiate
yacine prendre 18 mois dont 6 avec
sursis ce pas beaucoup oui
en prison il se comporte comme un
prisonnier modèle évidemment et il
obtient la liberté conditionnelle donc
été obligé de porter un bracelet
électronique
pour éviter qui s'approche de vous mais
il met en place un réseau d'informateurs
ça va être que des textos voilà tu as tu
attend le bus athées habillée comme ça
voilà tu dors déjà
alors dit qu'il a plus son bracelet
électronique il vient vous attendent
chez vous c'est encore pire qu'à vous
rentrez chez vous il est assis dans le
canapé
plusieurs fois où un jour chez moi et en
fait lui il est déjà à la maison
installée là vous décidez de faire un
programme d'éloignement dans un lieu
secret vous êtes accueillis dans un
appartement où séjournent déjà plusieurs
femmes victimes du même genre de mec 1
vous scolarisés votre enfant mais quinze
jours après la rentrée le programme de
protection vole en éclats yacine vous à
retrouver il est passé à l'école voir le
môme et voilà en fait tout simplement il
a appelé toutes les académies de france
jusqu'à tendre tombés dans le centre de
la france on lui a dit oui il est bien
scolarisés à cette école le 30 octobre
2013 au tribunal de grande instance de
versailles
yassine est condamné à un an de prison
mais il fait appel et il continue à vous
appeler jour et nuit ça ne changerait
rien 4 juin 2014 jour de l'appel
l'audience est reportée en janvier 2015
donc là les pouvoirs publics une fois de
plus ne font rien pour vous ils vous
laissent dans votre merde
finalement
yacine sera condamné pour coups et
blessures mais pas à de la prison et
quant au harcèlement il a été relaxé
faute de preuves en fait c'est pas ça le
problème c'est comme j'ai déposé plainte
dans plusieurs départements différents
en fait les départements se rejettent la
balle pour pas payer les réquisitions et
c'est pour ça que vous avez écrit ce
livre en fait parce qu'à un moment votre
seule solution c'est de se lasser de le
dire à tout le monde puisque les
pouvoirs publics ne vous écoute pas vous
avez décidé d'en faire une affaire
publique c'est quoi l'avenir maintenant
venir on verra la sortie du livre
6,6 alexis ii pas trop vous avez peur là
oui quand même je sais que ça va pas du
tout lui faire plaisir
donc on verra bien là c'est un peu au
jour le jour courage
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu